my father gave me an abiding and then  the other thing i should say about him  is he spent a tremendous amount of time  with me when i was very young say before  i was five or six he taught me to read  he did that every night for months and i  remember that very vividly and instilled  in me a love of books and a fluency in  reading  he  believed that i could do  what i set my mind to  and he really believed that and to have  someone that believed that  of you  that's something man  and you know it was something that i  wanted to offer to my clinical clients  you know because i did believe that  there was more to them than the  suffering person that was sitting there  and that you know with joint diligent  effort we could sift our way through the  chaff and find the wheat and that things  could be better and one of the lovely  things about practicing as a clinician  was that  that was that almost inevitably happened  sometimes really radically